hi Leon it's wonderful seeing you again
you will be one of the speakers at the
Nexus conference 2015 why not start with
introducing yourself my name is Leon
weaseled here i am the isaiah berlin
senior fellow and culture and policy at
the Brookings Institution I'm a
contributing editor to the Atlantic and
I do variety of other things thank you
um at the conference you will be in the
second debate the conference is entitled
waiting for the barbarians who are
today's barbarians according to you and
it depends if you mean barbarians
literally or metaphorically literally I
think we're living in a renaissance of
savagery of sheer physical cruelty in
the name of ideology and politics I have
in mind mainly Syria and Iraq and Boko
Haram and the savageries in Congo and
the unspeakable savageries in South
Sudan people the distinction that people
will people sometimes speak of these
barbarisms as anachronistic because this
is a 21st century and how can these
these these these ancient savageries
still be taking place and I think that
it's time for us to lose the feeling
that these horrors are anachronistic
they are as typical the 21st century as
they were
so you have the you have physical
barbarities but then there are cultural
barbarities in the sense that there has
been occurring a sustained assault on
the humanities coming from a variety of
sources coming from scientism but not
from science and from economists ism
though not from economics and from the
dominance of Technology upon the
thinking and the behavior of the Western
societies all of this amounts to an
assault on the humanities and if you
will I mean I don't want to call my
opponents in this debate barbarians for
some of them are highly cultivated
people but but the humanities needs to
be defended in ways that it never needed
to be defended I would like to read you
a quote from the famous American
theologian Reinhold Niebuhr who wrote in
1932 in his book moral men and emerald
society following the growing
intelligence of mankind seems not to be
growing rapidly enough to achieve
mastery of the social problems which the
advances of technology creates I think
stomach I think I think he's right that
some social problems are becoming
despairingly stubborn and i think that
there's a certain confidence that we
used to have in our ability to solve
problems which
longer I don't think all social problems
that we have are created by technology
and I don't think that technology will
solve all the social problems I think
that technology despite its massive and
excessive certain realms deplorable
influence that technology nonetheless
does not have as much power as some of
its proponents think it does which in my
view is good news not bad news and we'll
talk about obviously we'll talk about
the faith in technology in technology
zhem and in the and in the place that
technology has neither creating problems
or creating solutions to some of the
crises that will be talked in at the end
of the day what do you think in
protective only ourselves which is good
news in the bed I think that you know
Virginia Woolf once wrote that human
nature changed in February 1910 it was
one of the stupidest sentences
everything human nature didn't change in
1910 and it didn't change in 2010 and we
still are dealing with the struggle
between the good and the evil and every
human heart I know that sounds
sentimental and you can translate that
sentence into more scientifically
respectable or psychologically
respectable propositions but basically
the questions we face now in the 21st
century which is supposed to be
unimaginably advanced are some of the
oldest moral and even metaphysical
questions that people have always faced
and I think it's important to understand
for that reason that as we ceased to
educate
our selves in certain I was a
traditional values that sounds too
conservative in certain traditional
subjects and in certain traditional ways
of arguing we will make ourselves more
vulnerable and leave ourselves open to
the problems that we're deploring I
think that you know our faith in so far
as our faith was ever in our hands it
still is in our hands and so what we
think and what we believe and what the
reasons are for our actions or inactions
will still be the decisive factor in
determining the future it's still up to
us and all the iphones in the world
don't change that okay thank you we're
looking forward to seeing see you with
Amsterdam